hello everybody my name is Barbara and
welcome back to sport go evolve evolve
God Oh see it even shows your failures
honor you died there in the middle it's
okay and that's where you died to a baby
do you remember when you died to all
great accomplishments have their string
of failures but what I'm saying is do
you remember when you died to a baby
no I block because I'm pretty sure I
have a highlight here of a you die into
a baby you're gonna die you think baby
all right so what could it happen I
guess but still uh-huh so you did die to
that baby well here you have a chance to
redeem yourself because we're gonna be
on land now this is where things get
more complicated hit okay okay okay so
now we're gonna we're gonna swim off
with our knighted mega spiky electric
would and we're going to figure out how
to live what are you gonna do I like the
sound oh okay that's fun Ronny Soros
well that looks like us you kind of
backwards oh no wait oh that no that's
forward ear right you're right yeah
because our back is to the back I don't
think we need two legs I'm pretty sure
just we were anything we could get away
with one that looks pretty good that is
that actually looked very good but if I
may make a suggestion
yes if I may if I may if I may if I may
may I thank you if I may if I may
Oh Louis if I may if I may just make one
tiny although these units all yes I know
your your your imagination was almost
perfect in every way I wasn't done you
know sweet boy I know I know I know
about
like it was it was almost perfect even
though I didn't like it so if I had to
make just one itty-bitty change oh yes
yes okay and there we are the beautiful
size I think we are golden because this
is just about the I love our flat piece
now I didn't love everything about it
like we got our mouth up in front of our
wings on the sides where aerodynamic I
fly oh yeah I bet
we have tiny any many calves and tiny
feet our balance can be great
o our balance dad don't even worry about
our balance our balance is gonna be the
least of our problems
okay yeah good yeah okay no we got some
extra DNA so you gotta another tab here
that you can put up here sorry uh-oh
of course we come on right there oh yeah
when we RAM things we really want them
to know we're rinsable our nice bike
nipples yeah closer our boobs oh that's
much better that's a tasteful spacing
right there oh he's happy can you make
the back things any bigger okay okay all
right oh time rotate
where's his eyes he needs to be able to
see you just click on the outside of him
and turn him
don't ruin this somehow yeah get the
eyes and make them okay Victor fides of
public higher up okay nice you can't
have everything to me okay okay yeah
kinda looks like an elephant oh there we
go
we're beautiful this cannot be anaconda
trap any more now what is this name I
don't know alive
why it's we me leave me leave me leave
as you can see Oh gracious whim you
leave is wandering through the woods and
he [ __ ] a little bit of green Oh looks
like us oh this looks like a winner
Oh Oh God their beauty this is me we're
beautiful a bunch of meat
we're we're the oh okay I'm afraid oh my
god oh why am i alive is very weak Amir
leave we mean really holy we me leave
the embrace will and elegant creature
[Laughter]
like Pokemon it's the beginning of a new
day for you a whole new strange and
wondrous world you stretch your limb
into your new home dry land the race to
evolve it has begun just getting much
prettier oh so now I think you WASD your
way around blazing speed is unmended so
beautifully I may be in the ocean but
not here go talk to them
wait click on them okay aren't you
adorable we're gonna kill you okay okay
so you couldn't interact with this guy
in a fashionable or unfashionable way so
you've got a tax dance or a social
stance and right now you're in ataxia so
you can growl I do a raging roar you
and but I mean I'm just saying you have
options now but I mean yeah go range
we're coming for you see they run away
like little kill them kill them just use
your abilities okay eating it why are
you not doing you can press one groove
or that's your things okay
stop clicking down there you're telling
them to mine yours wonder for you
freaking idiot
okay okay you're fighting good good job
good kill them dead I'm winning I don't
know about that I don't know what the
score is you're barely winning you're
not doing so good race to the finish
okay race that's a good look that's a
nice mouth look at that winning smile oh
no we already you can tell make up baby
don't make that face oh and when you're
gonna make a don't make that face when
you make a baby don't make that face
okay that's my advice to everyone up
there when you mate when you go out to
the bar to make a baby with your random
folk of the evening eat something don't
make this face make this face no not
that one cycle completely different
please cycle wrong make this face
go My Goddess make keep going go go go
go top make that face whenever you want
to make a baby with your little evening
make that face you're welcome America
and everywhere else and we're healed
yeah hey did you make a baby yeah make a
baby oh that's a sexy lady right there
no what do I do
click on you trying to get us an under
this comfy nest of all there was a part
right there we already made this for now
okay yeah take off that mouth no sizes
and everything here small you sometimes
are able to do it okay yeah of course we
do this there's so many austere expense
here there are very expensive but here
if I may it may I may I have man okay
these as decorative as a mustaches are
not useful and and as decorative as
these are
it's just these these aren't no we're
not in the jungle anymore were civilized
species and that's a lot of change I
know it's a lot of change even these
needed we're gonna have it anyway just
because I know it's important you I know
it's important what's there to miss a
second mouth underneath oh there's one
more thing there's one more thing cuz
monopod obviously that ain't gonna work
so we need another stance B I like where
we're going with it
give him a big big the middle good
meeting point but big they're a smaller
where else
[Music]
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
Becky back it up oh oh oh we turn on a
dime though gallantly leaping the
beautiful incident we found the potato
species the was that oh the bean kill
the beat do it Oh Kelly was killing it
no no click with one press one dot look
at the things you did yes go get those
things after you're done oh come on for
we like crying from okay well I see
what's going on here kill more of the Oh
what's that
what is that oh that's Blaine everybody
go kill more of the things you retire or
the potato then to the right to the
right right there kill more all right
come here potato man click on him and
then charge him click on him go on in
you did not click on him I'm clicked
oh you suck you're more charge no it's
not ready he's too close and you get
closer good although to play in the way
[Music]
charging
you use on the space as we approach with
our anaconda that are in the Condor bus
or in a condom oh there's our lady mom
when you go to the club that's gonna be
with next to us oh my god testing you
with it's hitting you with the ice wait
hit the camera sexy eyes three two one
I think there's awfully insects whoa
whoa whoa thumping it as we go you gotta
like left-click wait just go backwards
and forwards I'm trying to wait nope go
backwards and forwards I owe
get the thingy oh wait I'll be the mouse
okay that's actually a good good
strategy so I'll be the mouse you'll be
the card that way we both can play yeah
we got cranberries - Achilles good yes
[Music]
munch munch crunch I think it's time to
go back and make another baby
[Music]
whichever one you all we're coming all
they do don't come near me don't come in
there oh you okay
let's do this whatever it is we're doing
need to click on the always spinning so
apparently we are the fimo could we lay
the eggs look at that one okay so anyway
thank you again for watching this is the
end of this party here we've been
playing long enough we're gonna keep
playing because we're still laughing and
then when we stop laughing that's for
murder so stop playing so we the way
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotation with more videos
check out Wade's channel in the
description below and as always we will
see you in the next video
[Music]